all right so you want to get into Cloud  well here is a resource I personally  wrote to make it easy for you to get  started whether you're new to cloud or  an expert I've taken a visual approach  in this book to help you start your  Cloud Journey from wherever you feel  comfortable there are eight chapters uh  and they go from basics of  infrastructure compute storage  application development networking data  and analytics machine learning Ai and  then it ends with security and each  chapter starts off with the basics that  apply to any cloud and then it goes into  more context with specific examples in  Google cloud and then finally each  chapter closes with a visual summary for  you to really register those Concepts  check out the book and let me know what  you think